[Music]
they said hey
i woke up cool today i woke up
later
[Music]
my name is dr hannibal lecter
hannibal the cannibal the papers called
me
you see i searched the world for the
greatest tasting meat and eventually
found it
human flesh
my first bite of a person was so
gratifying that it became my hobby
hunting and eating people
but the remarkable taste had worn off
as of late people meet had been tainted
with gmos gender hormones
and radiation from 5g
it lost its luster and i began to lose
my hope
until one day a doctor i was going to
have for dinner
brought me a container of good ranchers
i assumed the contents were the innards
of a moral farmhand
but inside the box
it was filled to the brim with bovine
cuts
i would normally pass but they called to
me
i simply had to try a taste of the
ranches
the meat was orgasmic
my mouth embraced a symphony of flavors
like never before
so succulent
so divine
it turned out human flesh was not the
most delectable and distinctive fair
around
it was good ranchers
so exquisite in fact
that it spared my dinner companion's
life
and brought me back to the splendor of
replenishment with earthly beasts
because good ranches
is great animal
that is a tasty animal
tell me doctor
do you have dreams
not anymore
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
strangers
[Music]
my word that is hot
really quickly gerald you just take this
real quick is your mouth on yeah yeah
get me off the screen
that's awesome i love it don't you know
that it's hot when there's smoke
billowing out okay come on all right i
apologize
oh everything's going to taste like an
old pipe ash tray for about a month oh
that's good
uh sorry that we started late today we
were uh taping filming to change my mind
yesterday we're going to have that crazy
day
monday what's the date monday
28th 28th monday march 28th and then
tuesday the 29th so we've got then we
have another one of the following monday
got a lot of stuff ruined my boots
though because uh i got shaked someone
threw a milkshake really could have been
a latte i don't know was it concrete
could have a flat white i have no idea
but they missed
it was harder to miss than to hit
so uh the women's softball team throws
better than antifa at uh unt university
of north texas i don't know if you know
this it's the heart it's the harvard of
denton county ah ooh nice so
[Laughter]
that'll be coming up not the greater
dallas fort worth metroplex area no no
it's the harvard of denton denton denton
county yes colin county is colin county
community college that's more than yale
there's better schools than tablets yes
like there are better schools
anywhere outside of the unt campus
area yeah
so uh
we have a lot we'll be talking about
today
uh the new world order not my words joe
biden's we'll be talking about uh the
supreme court uh right now oh look right
now uh this is happening as we are as we
are launching the show so you can see
nothing up my sleeve right in real time
kentaji brown jackson uh that's not
going to go very well so we're going to
be filling you in on exactly what's
happened the last couple of days as well
as i don't know if you know this sake
hillary clinton more covid and it turns
out the cdc obfuscated some of the
information regarding the vaccine
efficacy so we'll be talking about all
of that
but i do want to ask you before anything
else my question to you is um
what do you think former vice president
joe biden has planned
for the new world order
and
does he really think he's going to lead
it
that's a lot of responsibility for a
demented old circus monkey
quite a bit uh of course if you missed
this show if ever this show is not here
because we'll be talking about the cdc
today and that of course has got us it's
gotten us banned in the past monday
through thursday 10 a.m eastern we're
always streaming so if you don't see us
here on youtube right you bookmark the
patreon youtube notifications but go to
rumble or mug club lighthouse mug club
today we'll be playing hipster hobo on
mug club
taking your chat uh okay gerald a how
are you i am much better than you i
didn't get milkshaked yes or almost
milkshake didn't get flat-whited
drive-by milkshaked yes
it was a walk-by yeah they missed and i
couldn't tell if it was a guy or a girl
we're going through the footage like
forensically i think it was just a very
uh hippie
and i mean but i mean wide birthing hips
androgynous male but i'm not sure right
so you're saying there was 100 of space
and only 10 of that space was unoccupied
and that's what they hit instead of you
yeah anybody next to you they just went
right through yes who threw it fouchy
yeah
then he had it made into a custom
baseball card at tops i was aiming for
between yeah
i went through it where i wanted yeah
it's exactly it's just nailed it every
time
i got you right where i want you my mom
said it was perfect
now try my face to your fist style
this falls between you yes
and of course you know him you love him
uh landau dave on twitter dave how are
you sir ahoy good i did not get shaked
yesterday well neither did i it was it
was an attempt no i'm sorry yes i did
not stay well i probably got more shake
on me yesterday than you did then yeah
that's probably true
that's just because regular time you end
up making horrible decisions late at
night and five guys is just around the
corner that's correct yeah yes
i like the whip tapping i get excited
yes and it goes everywhere and shake
shack yeah everyone always has their
thing they get so they're such die-hard
fans well you guys let me know okay you
know we can let's just throw this out
there in and out five guys shake shack
what's your what's your burger of choice
i i don't know let's put that on a pole
yeah we can put it on a pole i don't
really know i just think okay and now
it's a little overrated but it's
delicious yeah it's fine yeah but i like
the neopolitan shake i'm not gonna lie
well you know who loves neopolitan is ll
cool j does he i don't know why i used
to play that clip all the time i was
like neapolitan ice cream got you
strawberry chocolate vanilla scoop on
the top yeah
i like a lot of stupid things blended
together like country music and hip hop
yeah
yeah like sharks and scientific
experiments deep blue sea like new
orleans and ncis or like me or like
cooking being a chef and a parrot yeah i
got a parrot on my shoulder in deep blue
that's my thing i'm the chef with the
parrot like a pant leg and shorts one
rolled up on one side yeah i call them
ports
like a dessert wine pantaloon did you
say wine
all right so uh we'll move on from this
but first uh i don't know if we're going
to react again we have a lot to get into
new world order covid the supreme court
justice uh who nobody likes and is not
qualified and uh by the way research
room let me know once we get uh once we
get that dame's lsat scores okay yeah
um
also uh also barack obama's let me know
when we get them congress wants to know
as well but uh stacy abrams uh
okay do you want to know how to ruin
star trek and i'm not a star trek fan
you make this is how you ruin star trek
you make stacey abrams president of
earth on the new star trek series star
trek series finale so this is how you
ruin star trek it's a two minute clip
but uh we have to do this yes today
we greet the president of united earth
united
[Music]
we are eager to begin diplomatic
discussions not funny when you're
surrounded in monsters they're like
there's no need for you right now to
rejoin the federation the only two
people who didn't get makeup were her
and clint howard
and ron perlman thank you thank you all
she didn't negotiate at all by the way
she just capitulated to everything they
wanted yes
no
succeeded louis anderson was the mom on
blasphemy you've recovered
yes i haven't had vaccinations
i would consider it a personal favor if
that were your last close call
i considered a personal favor if you
switched voting machines
captain may i have a word of course can
you switch space votes
i'd like to propose my new idea space
ballots have lived in the time before
earth left the federation
it means a lot
to all of us
that you threw all of those republican
ballots into that black hole
you got the borg to come in the
federation back together again has been
a great start
but there are countless worlds out there
still being is there still no nutrition
on earth
there are countless worlds for us to
destroy out there with our politics
we've needed to scour new planets are
you ready new sources of empty calories
let's get to it
we need to go to the sugar mines
she's like the aliens from signs only
she showed up to the planet what kills
her is vitamin d
[Music]
just m night shyamalan with invite
vitamin shot pills here take that
a stupid program twist is kale
[Music]
yeah i would never it stopped being good
uh when it the day after it started
hey look stacey abrams
you know
not even a good actress no
and i not that she's an actress but it
didn't even feel like an attempt i mean
it doesn't have a tough act to follow
too with uh you know william shatner
she's worse yes fantastic she's worse
and i look i appreciate your sarcasm but
she actually does appear later in the
episode um and then i will say
i i don't fair credit i want to give her
credit where it's due
um
because this the scale won't it's i want
she does pretty well she appears later
in the show and she steals the show
really
so it's gone finally
no no no no no guys that's the wrong
that's come on that's wrong that's
that's uh that's sars garden that's ours
oh yeah that's not the right clip that's
just starsgard covered in peanut oil
totally um
do we have yeah bring up the actual clip
of uh stacey rims later
yeah yeah nice strange yeah harrison
ford didn't take too kindly to her he
was like
those weren't supposed to be mail in
ballots
[Laughter]
get out of my voting booth
i'll send his fingers between her teeth
yes
that's all he does just hey
those those ballots are supposed to be
in a museum
yeah he's been get off my lawn guys
since the fugitive right yeah really
since regarding henry but half that
movie is just him trying to squeeze a
ball yeah
but i love that film yes i don't know i
actually do he's a vendor yeah it's a
really good if you want an actor to do
the most with the least amount of
dialogue harrison ford is very good yes
yeah and the scene where he gets shot
regarding henry is probably the most
realistic scene of someone getting shot
and we're just like wait wait wait like
he's just confused yeah and they copied
it in uh what was it called midtown rush
the uh was that what it was with uh uh
joseph gordon-levitt and what's his name
the guy uh oh rush
it wasn't just rush wasn't it midtown
rush when he's in the bike yeah he's on
the bike yeah i thought it was rush no
rush was the film with uh hemsworth the
driver yeah the point is maybe it was
maybe it wasn't homage
no no that's the kid with the guitar you
son of a [ __ ] right i never watched it
no you i think it is midtown rush it's
midtown rush anyway uh none of that
matters because hey premium rush premium
rush oh yeah that's a terrible what a
stupid title that's why we forgot it yes
you're right i am actually it's a badge
of honor yeah you're right we're all
right for not knowing that yeah that's
why the movie wasn't a hit hey you know
what i didn't think highly of you before
this show but you went up a notch in my
uh yeah it's true
that book of mine let me you know i'm
actually i'm gonna make a note
up one notch
you get a notch you get a half minute
why do i
don't break don't push it you know
exactly why but hey quarter black
quarter black garrett who doesn't uh
work full-time on the show but he still
comes in every now and then he just had
a son so we welcome to the world
1 8 black garrett
i texted him last night send your love
to him by the way comment below send
your love to quarter black garrett and
his uh his son
will be accepted amongst no communities
one-eighth is just enough to count
one-eighth is just enough to count and
so you can check the bucks it's more
than uh it's more than uh elizabeth
warren is native american it well a lot
she would kill to be one eighth anything
not white that's true
[Laughter]
she would kill anything white to be that
if she were one eighth black she would
be writing you know soul food collard
greens yes
and also if you don't like that how
about pow wow chow i have one one
thousand thirty four one of the blues
brothers yes
backup singer to aretha franklin what
the [ __ ]
all right
corpse
so moving on here uh this is a man who
uh look i've always said whoever is the
republican nominee
right in 2024 i will support yeah
whether it's donald trump whether it's
it looks like it's between donald trump
ronda governor ron desantis i like both
of them i think ron desantis comes in
with some less baggage than donald trump
but whoever it is i will support and i
do like governor ron desantis as a
governor uh this guy has a lot of the
attributes we can all agree uh at least
you know what you know i just want this
let's just make this whole thing in
conversation we'll read your comments
comment below whether you want donald
trump or ron desantis i'm curious
because they have the cpac poll yeah the
straw poll but that's a little bit
different and uh don't don't tell
everyone who disagrees with you in the
comment section that they're an idiot
someone can support donald trump for the
nominee that's the reason we have
primaries but i like governor desantis
and here's another example of why uh
yesterday he spoke out against uh you
know the ncaa uh women's uh i don't know
if you know this or some controversy
really there was some controversy
because it's uh the ncaa you know the
women's swimming yes championship i
don't
was won by a man
is that correct
i've not heard of this really yes it was
won by a by uh by a male and there's a
problem with this apparently ah that's
weird there's some controversy yeah was
it a white man
oh i don't know how he identifies okay
but
i i he seemed white then again he also
seemed like a man and i was wrong about
that well i don't see anything wrong
with a white man taking anything from
someone else no no especially not well
look let's be honest it's swimming so
it's only victims are largely going to
be white women is it michelle phelps yes
it's michelle phelps
it was what swims beneath get out of my
pool
oh boy seriously
you're not my wife you're a you're a
you're a demon child
you're possessed by stacey abrams so
get your balls out of my phone
[Laughter]
swam her balls off yes that leah thomas
swam her tits on yep shrinkage the only
sport where you benefit as a man
competing with from shrinkage
yeah because stanza could have taken
walked up beforehand to the officials
hey could you make the pool really cold
please
you know just saying just go a long way
so governor desantis spoke out against
this uh uh uh uh spectacle that was the
ncaa women's swimming finals and you
just gotta love them if you look at what
the ncaa has done uh by allowing
basically men to compete in women's
athletics in this case the swimming
you had the number one woman who
finished was from sarasota
eminent she won the silver medal she's
been an absolute superstar her whole
career she trains i mean to compete at
that level is very very difficult and
you don't just roll out of bed and do it
that takes grit that takes determination
and she's been an absolute superstar and
she had the fastest time
of any woman in college athletics now
the ncaa
is basically taking efforts to destroy
women's athletics they're trying to
undermine the integrity of the
competition and they're crowning
somebody else uh the woman's champion
and we think that's wrong and so in
florida i'm going to be
later today because this is a floridian
who i think deserves to be recognized
you know we're going to be doing a
proclamation uh saying
that emma
is the best female swimmer in the 500
meter freestyle because she earned that
hate speech which by the way actually
monday the 28th 27th 28th 28th monday
the 28th uh we have a change of mind on
just this topic
just a downbeat do we have it
and i was surprised when i did that that
changed my mind by the way uh this
probably toke now when you were there it
got to be the most caustic we had to
leave because it was getting pretty
dangerous the milkshake was funny yeah
but then people were getting pretty
angry the cops had to show up i really i
thought this was one of those issues
where it would be hard to find anyone
who would disagree turns out it wasn't
it turns out it wasn't at all but i do
love desentis made a good point you know
silver medalists the the the girl who
came in and the olympics silver medalist
you don't just you don't just roll out
of bed and that happens especially not
if you're rolling uh sideways over look
like leah thomas rolling over your boner
you ever done that in the morning by
accident yes when you roll over women
you don't know this when women say you
don't know you don't know pain you don't
give birth
roll over on your erection like a
kickstand with a head full of sleep in
the morning yeah
try to urinate with that thing yeah yeah
see what kind of morning like a super
soaker that can go around corners
except you can control the super soaker
right
[Laughter]
just grab a picture and angle it in yeah
so i and i really do i agree with what
desantis uh said there but i think that
he misses a major point look
this is a case
where um
the young women being impacted are not
nearly vocal enough and i've talked
about this in the past
you can only say to men for so long no
vagina no opinion right on abortion or
on uh taxpayer-funded birth control or
even if it's 16 out of 21 for a private
business like hobby lobby which is
considered you know hateful and
oppressive you said nope if you have a
penis you can't have an opinion well
guess what this is an issue that women
will need to solve young women you need
to solve this for yourself because
there's only so much that the man that
prince charming can come in and do for
you and i get it you're going to say
that sexist kind of is by definition men
are not allowed to have
a say and guess what if you look at the
polls this is something that always
interested me the polls used to be even
more severe but this is the most recent
one i think from gallup that we have
access to if there's a different poll
that's more recent more accurate i'd be
uh open to hearing it you could post it
below all our references are available
at lot of credit.com um
i think it's uh men okay this is from
gallup overlay a8 here men 72 percent or
sorry 72 percent were uh opposed
opposed to males competing in women's
sports 53
of women opposed well that's a good
start it's a good start but 43 of women
still believe that people should be able
to play in teams that match their gender
gender identity that's 43 that's almost
half of women wow right so this is an
issue where women need to you know what
needed to happen with leah thomas you
know what needed to happen
all the women all biological females and
this is a stupid this is why gender
theory is stupid because and you'll see
this with a change in my mind it used to
be sex is biological and gender is
social right gender is a social
construct and sex is biological go back
and watch the two genders change their
only two genders change my mind it's a
stupid premise but even going along with
that premise which is how i had to start
with this change my mind they cannot be
consistent with it because now they're
saying no gender is a societal construct
by the way uh someone can be born into
the wrong body and they should be
allowed to use their biological male
body to compete against biological
female bodies so now sex and gender are
interchangeable it was a grammatical
sleight of hand that was taking place
and you see where this ends you've got
it starts with
starts with fake fake mustaches taking a
dump in the target bathroom and then it
ends with men winning all the medals
yeah by the way we don't have a dog in
this fight we don't we we have noticed
there have not been women transitioning
to men coming over and dominating men's
sports yeah it doesn't happen like all
we're doing is trying to protect women's
sports so that you guys can compete and
not have a man take all of your first
place trophies right that's it we have
no dog in the fight in fact this is the
group of people that says men are the
problem we're like ha fine if you want
to be a feminist go for it but men are
dominating your sports right now yes and
they're good athletes i mean i competed
in some women's swimming and i came in
ninth yes well well you're doing better
well with five-year-olds dave i mean
look you can you could be a champion it
was bad no i don't know the
five-year-old you're thinking about the
pedophile segment that we're getting to
later with the supreme court justice
supporting them these were 25 year olds
thank you yeah come on and i was crying
he was hanging around by the college
it's sad for this girl though because
she has to take something that she's
earned yeah and look over her shoulder
and be afraid that she's taking
something that she's earned it's just
completely unfair yeah and yeah they do
have to stand up and i don't believe
that 53 uh percent of women only believe
that i believe that the rest are being
held at gunpoint yes and afraid to
actually share their real well this is
what's happening the ios the
international olympic committee a lot of
people don't know this they don't
require you to undergo hormone
replacement therapy at all what do they
do they punt it to the sports
organizations now what happens there
smaller sports organizations are
obviously more prone to succumbing to
the activist peer pressure right to the
cancel mob this is what happened with
the ncaa the ncaa said we're going to
let it be established by i believe the
the governing body is usa swimming but
there's one that was above them and they
said okay 36 months of hormone
replacement therapy which still isn't
enough by the way we'll have all of
those references when we do the change
my mind but then ncaa said nah not quite
you just need to tell us that you're
going through hormone replacement
therapy for a year and you have to
provide us with a test within four weeks
of competition where your testosterone
levels can only be twice that of a
normal female everyone good no you're
basically we talk about drug tests right
in sports and how they've become more
sophisticated and how people are
becoming more sophisticated at cheating
this is as this is a cheat sheet to how
to cheat imagine if someone said in
mixed martial arts in any other sport
just tell us that you're clean for the
year then provide us with one urine
sample
before the playoffs and you can only
have two times the testosterone levels
of all your male counterparts okay we
want to be fair what's the two times
balls yeah
well actually that's like you just look
at it and you're like yeah all right i'm
like huh i'm cd i'm seeing some anomaly
on your chart here those oh testicles
well that would explain that there you
go yeah perfect
welcome girl yes
so by the way there's so few women
speaking out against this
that uh people have had to create
stories yeah and this is one that a lot
of people in the conservatives fear got
wrong so originally there was a post a
twitter post attributed to um uh rika
georg or rika georg was the name
who missed out on the finals because of
leah thomas now these were the tweets
that were attributed to this person my
final spot was stolen by leah thomas who
is a biological male until we all refuse
to compete nothing will change well it
turns out that was fake right most
likely fake so it had to be but the
sentiment was true the sentiment is true
uh here's the problem you would like to
think that more women are coming out and
you know taking that
i don't want to say taking that stance
following the science remember that one
following the science following the data
but what actually happened is rika uh
did write a letter a letter to the ncaa
now this is one that we have verified
where she criticized the institution but
she also said this i'd like to point out
that i respect and fully stand with leah
thomas i am convinced that she is no
different than me or any other d1
swimmer who has woken up at 5am her
entire life for practice except when
leah thomas when she is waking up at 5am
she is waking up with a massive morning
erection
every swimmer steven no matter their sex
and she also pees standing up yes
around corners and this isn't about
waking up at 5am and training hard
nobody's saying leah thomas is not going
out there and training to try to be the
very best what we're saying is she is
training with an advantage this is
hormone privilege if we're going to talk
about privilege in society this gets you
leah thomas is the very very best among
women with a time that wouldn't even
place top 500 with men so yeah it's a
cheat yeah it's low down it's dirty it's
not fair this person competed as a man
for a very long amount of time and by
the way the the data shows that uh even
once you undergo hormone
i don't want to use the term hormone
replacement therapy once you go hormone
undergo hormone suppression you only
lose about five percent of your muscle
mass other strength of your total muscle
area volume within the first year and
not to mention look testosterone effects
and it's not just testosterone right now
this is the stupid thing too you want to
follow the science look i don't have
these references ready but i know that
we'll have them up on the website
testosterone specifically in utero and
testosterone
specifically in puberty what does it
affect everyone just wants to act like
it affects your beach muscles right like
it's mr olympia out there those atlas
cartoons because you're doing some bicep
curls it affects your muscles sure it
affects the density of muscles it
affects the fast the number of fast
twitch muscle uh muscle fibers it
affects connective tissue strength by a
factor of 80 percent it affects red
blood cell count it affects lung
capacity it affects vo2 max it affects
bone density and these things do not go
away once you stop testosterone if you
had testosterone in utero and if you
went through puberty with testosterone
guess what you have a huge portion of
those benefits for the rest of your life
despite the cancer that you may give
yourself by trying to inject yourself or
take pills of estrogen pellet whatever
it is that you want to use you will have
those benefits for a long amount of time
i know what you're about to say so we
need to put kids on puberty blockers i
think you should be arrested
yeah hey by the way speaking of arrested
we arrest
the audiences at our live shows we kept
really it's more captivation yeah uh
lightroom credit.com tour dave landau
and i are on tour may 14th the tulsa
ballroom in tulsa oklahoma there's
someone there it's a big one and then
that we did add uh we did add a show oh
yeah uh to uh colorado springs at pikes
peak center june 18th june 18th
pikes peak center get some get some
stand up in your life have some fun
you know yeah seriously come on out okay
you can be any gender
sure anything you want so long as it's
male or female no one will ask you yeah
yeah and you
just compete in transports why don't we
just have that i don't understand well
this is the thing right if gender is
separate from sex and we did this with a
change of mind where i said okay so then
how about we have a third category right
well no why because they want to compete
with uh women
i care
hey how many genders are there on
facebook now what are we up to 50
something 100 something hey how about we
have 100 something sports divisions well
there wouldn't be anyone to compete
against exactly because it's nuts
because it doesn't make sense anymore
okay because sports have been separated
and this is the this is why in some
sports it would say male and female
division and in other sports it would
say men and women's division people want
to act like oh no men and women are
different from male and female no
because never in their wildest dreams
not only 40 50 years ago just
10 years ago would they imagine that
leah thomas would be the national female
swimming champion i mean we used to make
jokes about people going into the
special olympics and not having a
disability and just beating everyone
what is that jackass no we used to make
jokes about transgender about males
beating women and now it's not a joke
well ladybugs was a do you think it
would be a documentary yes exactly it
was like i mean first step in the
progression we're like oh this is stupid
that kind of ends like one too
all right well here we are well this
brings us to uh what we're now uh facing
which is the new world order i know what
you're thinking hey
you know you're thinking alex jones was
right
i can't disagree
so uh on monday while speaking to a room
full of united states business leaders
uh former vice president joe biden
declared that um
not only was there to be a new world
order but that he wanted to lead it his
words not mine believe your lioness
inflection point i believe in the world
economy not just the world economy in
the world it occurs every three or four
generations
as one of them as the one of the top
military people said to me in a secure
meeting the other day
60 60 million people died between 1900
and 1946
and
since then we established a liberal
world order and that hadn't happened in
a long while a lot of people dying but
nowhere near the chaos
and now is a time when things are
shifting we're gonna they're gonna be a
new world order out there and we've
gotta lead it we've got to unite the
rest of the free world and doing it so
anyway
that's not good doesn't baiden remember
the last time a new world order was
found i can't remember when to take his
pills and he even has the case that says
which day to take which pills
and he can't do that unless he has his
bifocals and then he doesn't know where
to find them
[Laughter]
and by the way the last time that
someone tried to create a new world
order it i i remember i remember bash
beach at 96. it didn't end well nope
hogan arrived
[Applause]
[Music]
is this right here
is the future of wrestling you can call
this
the new
world order of wrestling brother
oh boy and there's a lot of speculation
as to what the new world order would be
can you can you name anything else that
former vice president joe biden has
because that seems like a tall order
that he's in which he's led yeah he he
actually is teaching people how to walk
upstairs that's good yeah yeah crapping
his pants to the vatican that's top time
i guess that he's a world champion uh
child sniffer you are you know you got
your visions you're good at certain
things and not others yeah great yeah
that works he has incredible lung
capacity he does
got to get those kids you can inhale
your soul he can tell you the year it
was born
[Laughter]
what happens when you have to overturn
all the alex jones lawsuits it's like
look look i told you that there was
going to be a new world order
i was right about that i was just wrong
about i never imagined that former vice
president joe biden would be leading it
and neither did he i got half of it
right do i get credit for getting half
of it right because i'm a human damn if
he's getting checks for half his money
back yes
frogs are gay check okay fine yeah a gay
frog drops it off
yeah here you were trying to ride ribbit
i would sooner trust a gay frog to lead
the new world order oh yeah
i trust a straight frog
i don't care i trust any frog
i trust dino dino dna
life finds a way yeah there it is uh i
would trust hunter over because crack
you know keeps you keeps you focused
yeah well at least it gives you energy
it gives you energy for cleaning but
that's about it
no one would he wouldn't run the risk of
being low energy hunter no no hunter is
so high energy do you see his energy
focus with he has so much energy hunter
he's always reason oh i don't remember
did trump would call him meth teeth
biden
look at mad at me
look at him
they fixed his teeth he pretends he's
sober
[Laughter]
please
let them run against each other somehow
okay uh which brings us to another uh
story you're speaking of new world order
people who would support it
i mean is there anything else to say
about look this is one of those things i
here's there's a value there's a real
value in having former vice president
joe biden uh
speak
there is
yes because he says those things that
you're not supposed to say that's true
barack obama would have couched it now
now there's going to be a new there's
going to be a an international uh global
initiative and biden's like what do you
mean you mean the new world order shut
down up joe
stop now stop stop stop do you mean the
new world order and uh the bilderberg's
nah nah i told i i told i told no i told
you not to talk about the bilderbergs
how about klaus schwab huh quiet part
out loud all the time you know we should
just give him the mic and get out of the
way
that's why they usher him off
it's between 1901 and 1946
1600 people died why is he up there
speaking yeah
everything he says is nonsense but i
want him to continue speaking for the
same reason i want stelter to get the
prime time slot oh i'm
oh please any questions for the
president no we would like to just have
him talk let him keep going
when you have athletes or you have
fighters say i want the best version of
insert whatever it is yeah i want the
best version of uh jon jones who's ever
been it's like that's stupid you want
the worst version you want him to show
up sick you want him to show up under
arrested you want him to show up maybe
you have some food poisoning you don't
want to fight the best like no joe biden
is
easy that's who i want
oh no ronda rousey didn't want to come
back and fight a fully well personally
no she didn't
we don't know that and also how that
turned out how do they deal with arm
bars yeah well you know
i lost a bet so uh for real should we
say you mentioned that uh schwab that
clown
yeah there's a rumor going around that
he has because he's supported the new
world order that he has coveted but we
weren't like the shadow leader of the
well not even shadow it's kind of out
there yeah well also a former vice
president biden is scared of shadows
well that's uh because you saw peter pan
well he thought it was an investment
company schwab yeah so
he's just like giving him money so uh
apparently he might have coveted that
but i can't confirm that but i can
confirm that
uh jen saki just tested positive passage
tested positive what were you about to
ask didn't she already test positive yes
yes october oh
october 2021
really yeah that's not that long ago
she's surrounded by people that are uh
you know supposed to be vaxxed i thought
well she is vex well herself as well
yeah she's vacs and she's surrounded by
people who are vaxxed and boosted yes
and boosted uh and uh not just hillary
clinton oh no
as well and she tweeted i'm more
grateful than ever for the protection
vaccines can provide against okay so sad
um
really
you're grateful for the you just tested
positive jen sackey just tested positive
twice
twice between october and march
two times and she's vaccinated at what
point do you say maybe i'm not so
grateful for these vaccines well maybe
i'm actually
dare i say it angry
at the ineffectiveness of these vaccines
i almost feel like i've been hoodwinked
if i may by the vaccine companies
well she also likes the guards that
watched epstein's cell so maybe she
doesn't like things that work yes
she also likes the cobalt lined bed
sheets that they put in his
[Laughter]
you mean the rope sheets yes it's just a
rope yeah it's just it's that thing when
you cut through a flexible bike lock
that's underneath the plastic that's
that that's what he was sleeping on that
so here's the thing too by the way you
might be wondering if you don't watch
this show very regularly oh and by the
way smash that like button if you're
watching the show that helps on because
right now as we get into the cdc guess
what
you never know what's going to happen
because youtube isn't a huge fan of the
science they already got rid of the
dislike button they already make it so
you won't be able to find this show if
you search it so just smash the like
button leave a comment that's all we ask
that you do if you want to support us
mug club but here's the thing if you're
just paying attention for the first time
you might be going wait a second weren't
they vaccinated yeah
yes go to some previous episodes we've
been covering this for a while uh here's
the thing the new york times just
recently reported on and this might
explain
and by may explain i mean definitely
does does uh
why the vaccines don't work the cdc
purposely
hid large portions of data on the
booster efficacy so they specifically
when they were talking about the
vaccines the cdc this is from the new
york times you can go and read it just
quoting excluded huge portions of the
booster the efficacy data for a pretty
big group of people 18 to 49 year olds
what
which
greatly changed the efficacy rates of
the vaccines i wonder why you would uh
get get rid of like yeah like i could
understand if it's like when i first
read this i thought oh they missed some
data points yeah yeah you know
like grad school students right
no 18 to 49 year olds by the way that's
the demographic that nielsen uses to
sell [ __ ] yes
it's just the most important and slash a
live demographic yes why
oh go good follow that follow that
follow that logic trail without getting
me banned another time no that's why i
stopped stephen do you know how many
times i've started to say something in
my head and stopped and everyone thought
it was dave who got a suspension it was
a fake never mind cdc information from
california of all places yeah i just
make jokes i don't i'm not even here
with all these facts getting us thrown
off
i'm just asking questions you know just
saying why would you exclude a group of
healthy people like that with some of
the issues that people have you know
talked through i've just i just asked a
question to do it more jeopardy style
though it should have been in the form
of a question of a question exactly do
your vaccine suck
yeah i don't know at what point do we
think yeah for taking it more easy on us
yeah
thank you it's a little less worse this
is just weird at that look if it doesn't
stop you from getting covered twice in
is that a period of six months october
through march
yeah let's call it six seven i don't
know i don't do the math that well going
through months let's see october
november december january february so
months yeah five six months i was about
right you know what that also coincides
with
the the typical flu season it's weird
that that is bizarre it's usually when i
thought you were gonna say it also
coincides with the recessive uh genetic
mutation uh among ginger gingers yeah
but yeah who knew hillary was a ginger
yeah well i don't know that she is or
not i know that jen saki um you know is
yeah yeah i mean she's aggressively so
very ginge offensively so yeah i mean
even carrot tops like
you scale it back yeah not interested
you mean because she's not a guy
[Laughter]
what
[Laughter]
he's more interested in what's his name
jim acosta okay
so this is where we are we have people
now who have tested positive we went
through a list of celebrities who had
been vaccinated tested positive now you
have people who have been boosted
they've tested positive multiple times
and now you see that the cdc excluded uh
the largest most important group
demographic from the studies that they
published and hey you know what the good
news is well it's not like that was used
to thrust this mrna injection upon an
unsuspecting public uh and uh of course
being done without any legal liability
for the companies well that's helpful
yeah good should it be wrong well they
have 75 years to you know release the
data so yes that'll work yeah oh good
well in 75 years we all look like the
elephant man yes
exactly
let's make that the rule for every drug
fine if you want to do that totally fine
let's play by that rule for every single
moment
i'm a human
being not so i can tell start spinning
us around
[Music]
hey by the way uh speaking of well
actually this is not a segue but uh the
show today brought to you by good
ranchers yeah good ranchers you saw that
commercial there at the beginning if you
go to goodranchers.com crowder use the
promo code crowder you get 30 off uh and
free express shipping look really
quickly just to let you know a lot of
your beef a lot of your meat that you're
buying at the grocery store doesn't even
come from the united states uh good
ranches they work directly kind of like
you know those mattress in a box
companies where they got rid of the
middlemen there's a lot of that in meat
good ranchers works with local american
farmers the highest quality standards
and uh they ship it directly to you you
get 30 off if you use the promo code
crowder and of course they have they
have the bows to sponsor the show so we
always ask that you promote i've eaten
their steaks there but here's what i
would say better than grocery store
steaks yeah i don't know like if you
compare it to like a usda prime
steakhouse where you're paying eighty
dollars for y but much better than
grocery store steaks yeah at better than
grocery store prices delivered straight
to you and it's frozen and it's frozen
at its peak fretness but yeah frozen at
its peak freshness the point is good
ranchers
absolutely buying walmart's steaks you
should first off you should it was
really good actually honestly really
really really good yeah and i'd eat a
lot of it if you can convert hannibal
lecter i mean it was really good well i
will say we had to handle electron
retainer we just didn't know what to do
with them so finally found uh finally
got our money's worth all right
now we move on to the supreme court
hearings and here's the thing
you've all been reading about this but
there are some key details that you may
have missed
and what are these key details namely
that i just don't know why the left uh
can't stop tripping over themselves to
support pedophiles
again well i'm usually able to argue
from the other perspectives you know
their point of view yeah
i can't hear
it's tough it's very hard to consider me
stumped yeah yeah it's very hard for me
to get beyond you know i get it this
sort of
i guess you would call it this binary
decision of
do we execute pedophiles
or do we make it look like an accident
when we execute pedophiles
right it's tough to say yeah or in their
case which is just
barely slap them on the wrist and make
sure they're in public all the time to
do it again right or what you can do is
slap them on the bottom but tell them
it's a 12 year old boy but really what
you have is you have like a little prick
a little cyanide yeah
i like that yeah that idea and then
they're like oh and you know what they
think that they die doing what they love
but but either way they're either way
it's a dead pedophile it's easy my point
is the end result is the same and it's a
good one yeah or uh you're in prison for
example and one of the guards
accidentally leaves your door open right
oh is the door open of the system and
we're back to the prick on the rear yeah
so uh yesterday uh this is the one
that's going uh viral uh the missouri
senator josh hawley um
really took it to the uh biden supreme
court nominee you know kentaji brown
kentonji brown jackson
uh over her light sentencing
yeah i'm going to make sure that i just
say this so it's as clear as possible
this is where you see a divide from
the well okay my right your left so the
right and the left
if you go to the twittersphere uh
twittersphere and you see people
discussing it people on the left are
going ha ha holly is an idiot right okay
that's how you you don't like him i
understand that whereas people on the
right are saying
i can't believe that this
potential justice
is lenient in sentencing child
pornographers now i think one is more
substantive than
your mom but he grilled her on
specifically her light sentencing of
child pornography
offenders here you go
i just want to ask you about that
because i just have to tell you i'm
having a hard time wrapping my head
around it we're talking about
eight-year-olds and nine-year-olds and
11 year olds and 12 year olds
he's got images of these the government
said added up to over 600 images must
have been an fbi agent gobs of video
footage
of these children
but you say this does not signal a
heinous or egregious child pornography
offense help me understand that what
word would you use if it's not heinous
or egregious
how would you describe it okay so let me
just be clear i want to get to her
answer
and all references available at
lightworkcrowd.com you can watch the
whole
grilling uh
she refused to label over 600 images of
young children uh pornography is heinous
or egregious right so he asked her
unbelievable what would you label it
yeah i feel like that's a pretty clear
question it is yes
here's her answer
thank you senator for letting me
address
the concern
that you've put forward
based on the record
that you've reviewed
as a judge
who
is a mom and has
been tasked with the responsibility of
actually reviewing the evidence
the evidence that you
[Music]
would not describe
in polite company
the evidence that you non-child
pornographers are pointing to
discussing
addressing in this context is evidence
that i
have seen
in my role as a judge
and it is
heinous it is
egregious well then okay then what are
we arguing about you said that it wasn't
and now you said that it was this answer
is just it's that double it's just it
seems it you know what it made me think
it seemed familiar made me think of this
10 people died in the bronx last night
due to a fire that killed 10 people in
the bronx last night during a fire
fire officials say all 10 people died
due to the fire which was too hot for
their bodies
back when satire was fun
[Laughter]
do you see the look on holly's face and
he's looking like what
that you would not describe in polite
company do you mean the people not
sexually abusing children do you mean
that polite company
can we just define who we're talking
about because generally look no one's
perfect
definitely not you no mostly not not you
come on and you know what you know who
else isn't perfect i don't know if you
know this
this guy right here
none of us are perfect as a point that
being said there is a category of people
and you can include people in all their
imperfections right all their stretch
stretch marks all their their pock marks
all their all their idiosyncrasies all
of them and still separate them from
child pornographers with
600 pieces of which are heinous
and you basically were i guess coached
by kamala harris's team on how to answer
questions at the senate hearing she just
felt he should do the exact amount of
time in jail as the age of the youngest
child right yeah that's a good sense i
think that's a good way a rule of thumb
for her do we know can we can we find
out what the sentencing was well we'll
get to that because we're going to go
through top three moments at least with
some other examples because ted cruz
lasered right in on this before so we'll
go back to it where he actually shows
the sentencing and how it was reduced oh
i'm getting ahead of myself i read on
yes i know
you did your research so that's why i
said you're not you're not perfect but
you're pretty good i looked into her and
she's uh it's pretty awful yeah yeah the
fact that she can't answer any questions
it's just it is heinous it is egregious
great
why are you here yeah why are you here
oh wait that's right i know why oh i
figured it out
what did he say oh black female that's
right black female black female what are
the qualifications black and female yeah
but what are her lsat scores what are
black and female need i say more you
certainly do especially considering the
fact that she's defending child
pornographers michael
so let's go to uh the top this just
happened today
uh yesterday sorry but uh
it's hard to piecemeal things together
and so let's go through the top moments
uh that have occurred i would say in the
last two days uh with this supreme court
nominee uh moment
number three
this is when uh
senator marcia blackburn um went in
to
a question
okay you know what i'm not going to try
and be flowery marsha blackburn asked
this potential supreme court justice the
most powerful court in all the land if
she could define a woman
do you agree with justice ginsburg that
there are physical differences between
men and women that are enduring
um
senator
i'm kind of [ __ ] respectfully i
am not familiar with that particular
quote or case do you women interpret
justice ginsburg's
meaning of men and women as male and
female
again because i don't know the case i
don't know how i interpret it i need to
read the whole okay
uh can you provide a definition for the
word woman
can i provide a definition no yeah
i can't
you can't or you wow
not okay this context i'm not in biology
can
someone grab a dictionary they're not
called dictionaries anymore it's too
inclusive they're not called chineri oh
okay
in the [ __ ] mine
well look it's crazy because essentially
like this is a left gotcha moment but
they have done the math and it's better
to look like an idiot apparently to sit
on the supreme court than to say
something that's true yeah yeah just on
pc yes exactly they have to they have to
not offend their constituents this is
the thing it's like when people say oh
the left and the right are so divided no
no look hold on a second i don't think
that most americans even who vote
democrat would be mad if she said yeah
woman you know
tits vagina you know
me sitting here right now he's sitting
here really howdy uh miss uh jackson
brown how do you know that you're a
woman uh
okay got it yeah
did i say more i came out with these
chromosomes
[Laughter]
your honor could you tell me if water is
wet respectfully
i cannot
she must have gotten her degree from the
university of north texas by the way
that changed my mind coming on monday
the 28th
yeah there you go
he was at the university of north texas
the harvard
of denton county
[Laughter]
twu is pissed off it's right next door
it's like don't worry about harvard no
no no there's the brown ah
yeah
because they too banned asians oh come
on they don't need to pan asians from
unt
hopscotch brown not yellow
ouch so this brings us to moment number
two and this is when uh senator there
you go thank you senator ted cruz uh
went after uh jackson on critical race
theory
catching her in a little bit of a a
little bit of a sticky uh situation and
by that i mean he had facts and she
didn't like it
but i've never studied critical race
theory and i've never used it it doesn't
come up in the work that i do as a judge
so so with respect i find that a curious
statement
because
um
you gave a speech in april of 2015
at the university of chicago in which
you described the job you do as a judge
and you said sentencing is just plain
interesting because it melds together
myriad types of law criminal law and of
course constitutional law critical race
theory so you described
in a speech to a law school what you
were doing is critical race theory
and so i guess i would ask what did you
mean by that when you gave this do you
think that's significant respect senator
um the quote that you are
mentioning there
um was about sentencing policy it was
not about sentencing
i was talking about
policies
determinations of bodies like the
sentencing commission when they look at
a laundry list of various
academic subjects that affects what as
they consider what the policies should
be the problem the sentencing is the
direct result of what is she in regards
to what is she saying
i
i believe it's called lying hence her
fiery pants that's yes her pants were
her pants were sponsored by ja rule
they're smoldering
it's her pants island and by the way if
i were ted cruz i would have a
professional sign carrier like they have
like five guys or a furniture sale just
spinning it spinning it
he's just yeah critical race theory
bouncing around two feet is one of those
inflatable things yeah exactly use car
lots they just tape over el pollo loco
and it's just crazy theory how did she
think like ted cruz is showing up with
props this probably doesn't involve me
i shouldn't read that in advance
you shouldn't even think just go hey
senator cruz yeah what
what'd you get over here what's that oh
yeah maybe i'll just go say hello and
take a sneak peek yeah take a snake you
have a hype man yeah just sit here
ladies could you hand me the giant sign
i brought in that she didn't notice
if i were questioning if i were a part
of these hearings i would have a hype
man i'd be like interesting that you say
that because i see that you have a right
here describe it as critical race or
have someone in back me going oh [ __ ] oh
no oh damn oh
flavor flav popsicle
you just got clues missile
[Laughter]
oh you going cruising
[Laughter]
are you cruising full of frozen life of
life like okay that's enough i don't
need you to say your name yeah please
every time yeah just stop bringing it
brought to you by flavor flav
we saw the clock sir the drink he's
promoting yeah like there's a lot of
alcohol in this
yeah
yes yeah i got problems yeah i shake
also it might not be that might not be
potable alcohol yeah we just got it from
a rubbing bin i've made it in my
bathroom and my cousin gone blind
which brings us to moment number one
right you saw josh hawley asking about
the child pornography this is not the
first time she's been asked about this
and this is just something that i don't
well i do understand why
but i'll
i'm being facetious here i'll play dumb
i don't understand why the left supports
right you know pedophiles and child
pornographers oh who can figure it out
uh because i don't want to get banned
we'll talk about it on mug club yeah
talk more about pedophiles and child
pornographers on mug club and why the
left defends them because that's kind of
speculative but cruz senator cruz and
he's he's look senator cruz has had his
slip-ups he has but he did uh come with
notes and absolutely
i would say crushed uh her on her
sentencing record you asked this
question yeah specifically on child
pornography crimes and yes another
billboard yes
every single case 100 percent when
prosecutors came before you with child
pornography cases
you sentenced the defenders to
substantially below not just the
guidelines which are way higher but what
the prosecutor asked for on average of
these cases
47.2 percent less now you said you made
sure
the voice of the children
was heard do you believe in a case
like united states versus hawkins
where the prosecutor asked for 24 months
and you sentenced the offender to only
three months do you believe the voice of
the children is heard when a hundred
percent of the time
you're sentencing child pronoun those in
possession of child pornography to far
below what the prosecutor's asking for
yes senator i do
47.2 percent less time is what she is
average with sentencing for child
pornographers or sex offenders what are
you you're not negotiating a mortgage
right so so the example that he just
gave the sentencing guidelines started
at 97 months right the government
requested 24. two years she gave him
three guidelines 97 sentence three
just for context cruz was being nice
it's almost like there's no consequence
for child sex offenses it's insane if
i'm a child sex offender
and i know i'm getting three months
that's 90 days i go without you know sex
offending a child that's not so bad
that's nothing
it's just pathetic
and i know that look the details of the
kids you never subject matter isn't
changing we're talking about child
pornography and we're talking about
child i guess some of these maybe like
interactions actually physically
touching a child right but the
possession of 600 pieces of child
pornography that's the kind of stuff
we're talking about and the government
says well we only want 24 months they're
wrong for asking for 24 months when it
should start at 97. she's wrong for
giving three yes and by the way i don't
want to be a stickler
right so like one piece of child
pornography maybe you found yourself
stumbling across i'll even give you what
i like
like there's the ten pieces and i'll
even give you what i call the grace
child pornography item maybe eleven but
after that
um something tells me it may not be
accidental i think 600 is beyond that
threshold and you should no longer be uh
you know breathing oxygen yeah i agree
there's i give you i give you the uh
yeah
you're the fellini of child pornography
i think the three strikes in your route
policy yes pretty good yeah three
strikes and each child pornography uh
like pornographic image counts as a
strike yes yeah because you can't have
three strikes and each strike by the way
sub 600 strikes right
then that would be 1800 child
pornography strikes i guess that's a
full magazine yeah like if something's
hacked or sent to you that's a different
thing of course yeah right right so you
take that out but if it's like you got
it again pete townsend yeah three
strikes and you're out yeah jeffrey
jones talking to you but it does beg the
question why does the and this is this
is a trend this is absolutely a trend
that is undeniable
and
well i think of course for the same
reason that she can't answer what a
woman is is once you eliminate the lines
between man and woman once you eliminate
the lines of gender of sex well now
biology is a figment of your imagination
think about this for a second the left
who want to take jokes literally and
that's happened with this show and
you'll see it with change my mind by the
way someone takes a joke literally but
then says that a fact is subjective you
have a group of people
yes it's just don't don't don't want to
spoil anything it's going to be fun
sorry but the left who wants to ruin
your life they want to ruin your life
your lives all of you
by taking a joke literally don't want to
take biology literally don't want to
take irrefutable facts statistics data
literally so subjective realm of art
this is why they want to take it
literally because it's really used
it's to be weaponized against you
something that's undeniable look this is
an adult this is a child this is illegal
well no hold on a second those
sentencing uh
recommend that's that's subjective at
this point we don't want to take it
literally what what's what's the risk of
taking the minimum recommended
sentencing for child pornographers and
sex offenders literally
what's the risk
what's the worst that could happen
that a sex offender actually spends that
amount of time behind bars and again
we're talking about 600 images in one of
these cases and we're talking about
cases where they weren't even denied it
they didn't deny it
but yep that was me yeah
as an artist wants to you know take
credit for their work yeah do we
honestly think and i'm look i maybe
there's an example of this do you
honestly think that somebody who has 600
pieces of child pornography in their
possession has not tried to act on it do
you honestly believe that that's how
this works right that's not how this
works it's not like forgetting to return
a blockbuster tape without rewinding it
right it's like forgetting to return 600
blockbuster tapes that all happen to be
child pornography tapes right and you
didn't rewind them and you didn't return
them yes i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm not
taking and you created them yes i'm not
taking that
[Laughter]
think about it though there's a long
history of this of age sex tape
sure i don't want to see you servicing
yourself no no no no no more of that
that's the only kind i make i was i'm an
artist listen don't be afraid to dream a
little bigger love here's the thing
i say this but let me give you some what
you have you have joseph frozenbaum
right who kyle written how shot and the
left venerated him as a hero you have
roman polanski r kelly kevin spacey
jeffrey epstein dan snyder right this is
one of the you have these issues they
constantly
recur nambla is an actual organization i
got into a fight yours truly right one
of my researchers with the salon.com
pedophile who wrote i'm a pedophile but
i'm not a monster then we did some
research we said actually this person is
still actively grooming children salon
allowed several subsequent pieces to be
uploaded and they were titled my week in
the right wing hates fear
well i don't do you mean that
we hate that you're a pedophile
i guess
i guess you can say that's hate speech
guilty
guilty as charged sort of like you are
of pedophilia so we're both guilty of
stuff
what do you think genuinely comment what
do you think the compulsion is for the
left to consistently either downplay
child sex offenses pedophilia child
pornography we saw this with i believe
it was the fbi or the cia where they had
these uncompany laptops mind you and by
company i mean your tax dollars
computers
if we talk about common ground
well look we are obviously not at the
point where we we can find common ground
on the idea that biological males
shouldn't be allowed to beat women right
that's no longer a common ground that's
a controversial topic wouldn't have been
controversial by the way when barack
obama came into office do you know how i
know because he entered the office
against gay marriage the first president
to take office who supported gay
marriage ever was donald trump barack
obama changed his opinion later on
think about this michelle obama had the
let's move campaign let's boil that down
what was it don't be fat cause it's bad
that's really what it was well that's a
controversial topic now because we have
fat pride
do you really think we have a hope with
and yes i mean this the right and the
left common ground in
no leeway
no leniency
no grace for child sex offenders you
already see that schism yeah and by the
way i'm not saying that all
liberals
all leftists support child pornographers
just the ones who are being nominated
for the supreme court just the ones who
are the heads of the party just the ones
who are the heads of the media
organizations that made joseph rosenbaum
out to be a hero who had committed many
many many
child
rape rape children sodomized children
just to be clear
so i'm not saying that everyone on the
left supports this but i am saying
only people on the left support this
find me any
find me the most controversial [ __ ] you
can on gorsuch you can on on on
kavanaugh for christ let's go back to
clarence thomas
right the controversy here is hey why
didn't you sentence these people to the
minimum
sentencing who had 600 pieces of child
pornography well i don't know and
ah clear a clear answer is going to
evade me here something you can't say in
polite company let's go back to clarence
thomas do you realize that clarence
thomas they tried to say this is a black
man who by the way in front of the
former vice president biden used the
n-word repeatedly not saying he's a
racist because if you take it into
context and just saying that would be
completely unacceptable today they tried
to attack him claiming that clarence
thomas went to a regularly uh
patron a pornography video rental place
turned out not to be true because when
he lived in that area that pornography
rental place didn't exist at the time
what they ended up nailing him on though
that was
undeniable clarence thomas was he had a
diet coke can in his office and a little
short curly could have been an eyelash
could have been whatever but instead he
decided to go the joker out and said hey
who left her who put their pubic hair on
my diet coke
i'm thinking that's awesome i want to
party with thomas
that's how they attacked him as a sexual
deviant today
you have a party that provides safe
harbor
for child
pornographers
you can't find anything like that on the
right that's why i'm a conservative not
a republican i don't have an r next to
my name but when people say oh i take it
on an issue-by-issue basis well guess
what this is kind of a non-negotiable
issue and if
you support child pornography or if you
support lenient sentencing or if you
simply aren't harsh enough on child sex
offenses guess what guarantee you
without beyond any shadow of a doubt
today you line up on the political left
how am i so confident in making that
making that bet
well you know what make your own
inference but tell me i'm wrong you can
comment below we're going to talk more
about this because gosh you know what it
might get heated i tend to get that way
when talking about child rapists and
child pornographers so let's go to mug
club because youtube well and by the way
look youtube like we can't find a single
child pornographer in your offices at
palo alto piss off